[Musique]
entretiens politiques avec véronique
matignon maire de rambouillet bonjour
madame bonjour alors rambouillet bas
c'est une ville que que tous les
français évidemment comme s ils ont
entendu parler du château de rambouillet
qui a longtemps était indépendant c'est
un lieu de pouvoir c'est de là qu'est
partie d'ailleurs la libération de paris
en 1944 et puis aussi des personnalités
connues
évidemment gérard larcher qui a été
maire de rambouillet qui est aujourd'hui
président du sénat et puis une dame
alors que les plus jeunes ne connaissent
peut-être pas ca clinton patenôtre qui a
été maire de rambouillet qui était une
grande femme politique à un moment on ne
parlait pas encore de parité et vous
n'êtes donc pas la première femme maire
de briller vous êtes lettre la deuxième
et c'est assez symbolique finalement
qu'est-ce qui vous à vous inciter à à
vous engager dans cette note dans cette
voie est ce que vous êtes infirmier
ronde et reviendra peut-être plus tard
est-ce que c'est le goût des autres
alors probablement le goût des autres je
suis arrivé un peu par hasard
j'oserais dire puisque j'ai commencé le
mon premier mandat électoral avec
monsieur larcher qui avait décidé
d'avoir dans son équipe des personnes
avec des profils très différents
à l'époque j'étais mère de famille
nombreuse travail en ayant probablement
un profit qui l'intéressait j'avais été
investis et dans de l'associatif dans
différents mouvements et puis donc j'ai
fait mon premier mandat avec lui en tant
que président de la commission petite
enfance et le mandat suivant était celui
de l'adjointe aux affaires scolaires et
familiales
et lorsque monsieur robert mon
prédécesseur a dû prendre la décision
douloureuse de ne pas optimisé pour des
raisons
santé il m'a demandé j'avoue que j'ai
été très surprise et que j'ai demandé
pas mal de temps d'autres mecs ion avant
de prendre cette décision mais oui mon
engagement n'est pas un engagement
politiciens mais bien un engagement pour
travailler pour les autres un peu dans
le même profil que ma profession
d'ailleurs vous l'avais dit dès votre
élection vous vouliez être une mère de
proximité ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'au fond le baril est au service de
ses administrés
alors il est tout à fait au service de
ses administrés il est là en soutien
et dieu sait si la période actuelle le
monsieur ressentir cette proximité est
plus qu'importante elle et elle est
essentielle
je vais tout à l'heure après cette
interview et avant un autre rendez vous
le rendre en ville soutenir aussi les
commerçants qui sont dépités de ce qui
leur arrive de nouveau c'est très
important c'est aussi ce qui s'est passé
lorsque j'étais dans mon mandat
précédent avec les parents d'élèves
c'est aussi avec les enseignants ce que
j'ai fait sur le mandat précédent
il est important d'être présent d'être à
leurs côtés dans tous les moments
faciles difficile sur le centre de
vaccination par exemple j'essaie d'y
passer un maximum de temps ça me permet
de voir
bien entendu les concitoyens mais aussi
tous les professionnels qui actuellement
oeuvre pour essayer de vaincre cette
pandémie dire vous continuez vous visez
vous étiez affirmé avoue être toujours
infirmière je crois que vous continuez
de deux jours par semaine à exercer
cette profession
c'est là aussi une façon de rester au
contact des habitants de partager aussi
bine parfois leur déception parfois leur
bonheur ça arrive
alors oui c'est une décision
ça fait partie des des conditions que
j'avais misé pour pouvoir
exercer le mandat actuel c'était de
pouvoir rester dans cette profession
auquel je suis à laquelle je suis
extrêmement attachée
donc je suis infirmière dans un réseau
de santé je ne sais pas de soins en soit
je prends soin d'eux en étant une
infirmière coordinatrice en parcours de
soins en gérontologie
ma spécialité et c'est une façon de
rester dans la vie réelle et comme je le
disais je ne suis pas politicienne ça
n'est pas ma profession de faire de la
politique et je tiens absolument à
garder cette attache auprès de la vie
quotidienne et de ce qui se passe
réellement ne pas être détaché de la
réalité quotidienne alors fait partie de
la dizaine de berre qui a été reçu par
le président de la république emmanuel
macron avant la noce des décisions de
confinement qui ont eu lieu jeudi
comment s'est passée cette réunion
qu'est ce que vous buvez de quel est le
message que je vais porter est ce que
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir été
entendu alors il nous sommes retrouvés
face un président de la république était
là pour nous écouter nous entendre sur
les difficultés que nous nous
rencontrions et comment nous pouvions
voir les choses moi j'ai beaucoup
insisté sur la vaccination sur les
difficultés à faire vivre un centre de
vaccination
actuellement ne serait ce que par le
nombre de professionnels de santé que
cela demande et de faire attention à nos
professionnels de santé qui sont tombés
eux aussi épuisé je lui ai relayé aussi
les difficultés que nous avons sur le
terrain face aux personnes qui ne
comprennent pas les directives et qui
bien entendu se tournent
systématiquement vers la proximité c'est
à dire la mairie
ce que je comprends parfaitement mais
notre difficulté nous aussi à pouvoir
être pédagogie être pédagogue dans nos
explications
et puis je lui aussi remonté
difficultés que nous rencontrons avec
les services lorsque nous avons des
directives qui tombe et que nous devons
les mettre en application extrêmement
rapidement
cela demande un exercice très périlleux
parfois de la part des services avec des
décrets qui nous arrive à des heurts a
c'est impossible et qu'il faut mettre en
place
extrêmement rapidement j'en veux pour
preuve par exemple ce qui se passe là
aujourd'hui nous attendons encore à
cette heure ci les décrets des décisions
et que je prends un exemple très simple
pour le marché demain matin eh bien nous
devrions peut-être prendre des
directives que nous n'allons pas pouvoir
prendre puisque les décrets vont arriver
probablement ce soir tard tard dans la
soirée
c'est vrai que les maires se sont
retrouvés au premier plan dans cette
lutte contre la lacc au vide au fond
n'était pas forcément d'ailleurs préparé
c'était pas forcément leurs compétences
mais c'est vrai qu'ils ont eu un rôle
majeur dans cette crise parce que
peut-être de soutien et parfois de
remplacement de ce que l'état ne pouvait
pas faire là vous vous avez insisté vous
avez raison de le faire sur la
vaccination à rambouillet où on va
pouvoir se faire vacciner rapidement je
crois que c'est un des points que vous
avez abordé notamment avec le président
de la république oui tout à fait alors
aujourd'hui déjà nous vaccinons nous
avons vacciné depuis le 18 janvier
environ 5300 personnes
sait on peut se dire c'est beaucoup et
pour nous c'est vraiment très
insuffisant il y aurait une vague énorme
affaire et il faudrait que nous
puissions faire ce que l'on appelle de
la vaccination de masse pour cela encore
faut-il avoir les vaccins
la grosse difficulté que nous
rencontrons nous sur le tient le terrain
en tant que maire mais aussi en temps
personnel soignant qui sont bien entendu
extrêmement questionné sur ce sujet là
c'est le manque de vaccination est là
préhension de nos concitoyens sur le
fait que nous ne décidons pas décrit nos
deux rendez-vous de vaccination que nous
ne faisons que mettre des créneaux de
vaccination en fonction des dotations
qui nous sont attribués
c'est très compliqué à faire comprendre
et évidemment cela amène de la colère
que je comprends parfaitement que je ne
juge pas bien ou deux au contraire je
sais l angoisse que représente cette
épidémie pour beaucoup de de mes
concitoyens mais c'est une vraie
difficulté donc le président nous a
promis une arrivée en masse de doses et
nous nous mettons en ordre de marche
pour pouvoir vacciner en masse mais ce
matin le président du nahd sur notre
nation
les professionnels de ce fait lui ce qui
bloque aujourd'hui ce qui vous lie chez
nous en ile-de-france ne finit que ce
soit médecin centre et c'est à dire que
il faut systématiquement les personnes
passent devant un médecin pour être
vaccinés ces ex un pompier garant du bon
déroulement de la vaccination et qui est
en responsabilité de cette vaccination
est évidemment et bien n'allons pas
pouvoir multiples et lénine de
vaccination si nous n'avons pas
suffisamment professionnels qui nous
rappelle sont eux mêmes sur le terrain
de façon quotidienne
donc il va falloir que nous puissions
avoir un assouplissement des règles pour
pouvoir être rejoint par les banques
n'est la protection civile
voire pourquoi pas les militaires si
nous devions vraiment maxime ou mac
signer en masse ce que nous espérons
vraiment et les infirmiers ou les bons
alors les infirmiers nous les avons sur
place
sont présents la difficulté que nous
avons est plus au niveau des médecins
parce que dès que nous n'avons pas un
médecin sur une ligne et bien y'a pas de
vaccination possible c'est pour ça que
je parle des médecins et les infirmiers
sont essentiels les sages femmes vont
nous rejoindre
les pharmaciens également donc j'espère
que ça va nous permettre d'avancer au
très nettement parce que nous sommes
disposés à mettre d'autres d'autres
locaux s'il le fallait à élargir à faire
même du drive nous sommes en train
éventuellement de penser à faire un
drive fac-ci de vaccination pour
vacciner vraiment en masse alors on le
voit que cette crise de l'accueil
d'événements au cslc la principale
préoccupation est de la population est
forcément des élus comme vous enfin un
mot peut-être pour conclure de
rambouillet qui est une est à la fois
une ville d'à peu près 30 et l'habitant
mais aussi une grande partie rurale il
ya la forêt la forêt de rambouillet
c'est une ville qui seule la qualité de
vie quand on est maire d'une ville comme
rambouillet qu'est ce qu'on se dit qu'il
faut maintenir cette qualité de vie ou
alors est-ce que vous avez aussi des
grands projets peut-être de
transformation de la ville alors très
important de préserver la qualité de vie
je suis à un an dès les élections je
suis à un an de cette campagne
électorale que j'ai fait sur le terrain
et je repense chaque jour il n'y a pas
un jour qui passe sans que j'y repense à
tous les échanges que j'ai eus avec et
rambolitains et leur désir de préserver
cette ville qui est en fait une ville à
la campagne
donc oui il ya des grands projets des
grands projets mais devant classe e les
services à la population améliorer faire
une place dans le centre ville de la
place de la mairie la transformer en une
place mots plus de parking en surface
mais met au bio conviviale il m'a aussi
un projet de pôle culturel et sportif
sur le quartier particulier delà de la
ville de rambouillet quartier de la
louvière une faut aussi nous travaillons
sur l'urbanisme comment school et c'est
la raison pour l'appel avons leur vision
il faut bien sûr que nous continuons à
travailler sur la construction de
logements sociaux à développer notre
ville mais dans une croissance qui soit
tout à fait raisonnable pour pouvoir
préserver cette qualité de vie qui est
nalement le le symbole de la ville de
randonnée et de ce pourquoi des
personnes de l'extérieur souhaitent unir
à devon d'accueillir une nouvelle
population
mais je me dois en particulier et encore
plus particulièrement de préserver et
laurent boullier de rambo monta actuelle
on continue à se sentir vraiment bien
d'avoir un autre là la crise sanitaire
naturellement au fil des projets que
vous avez beaucoup de travail nous on y
reviendra l'espère de temps en temps dit
on ira rambouillet parce que c'est une
ville magnifique
merci beaucoup wernig métillon et et
courage alors pour pour vous exercez
vous fonctions et en même temps
continuer à exercer votre votre métier
d'infirmière merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]